nous sommes avec Lucas Aubin docteur en
géopolitique à l'Iris spécialiste de la
Russie Lucas Aubin bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur France 24
en annonçant cette mobilisation Vladimir
Poutine le président russe n'a pas admis
hier le moindre échec militaire mais
pour celui qui pensait conquérir le
crâne en seulement 3 jours c'est
clairement un aveu de faiblesse
oui bien sûr on est sur on est sur un
faiblesse cette mobilisation partielle
intervient au moment où l'armée russe
connaît de nombreux revers sur le
terrain on sait que les
contre-offensives ukrainiennes depuis
deux semaines ont été très efficaces et
on attendait justement la réaction de la
division Poutine il s'avère qui lui
restait peu d'atouts dans sa manche
finalement et la mobilisation générale
en été un et il a choisi finalement de
prendre une demi décision à savoir la
mobilisation partielle néanmoins cette
il se met lui-même en difficulté dans le
sens où pour la première fois depuis le
début de son invasion du 24 février
dernier il a fait rentrer dans toutes
les maisons russes la guerre avec un
grand Angers évidemment et on va en
parler de cet impact sur les Russes mais
d'abord sur le terrain est-ce que cette
mobilisation partielle donc qui concerne
300 000 personnes va changer quelque
chose au cours de cette guerre
alors c'est évidemment très très
difficile de le dire néanmoins ce qu'on
peut ce qu'on peut dire c'est que les
300 000 personnes qui vont être
mobilisées si tenté qu'il y en ait
uniquement que 300 000 puisque
aujourd'hui on parle déjà de de beaucoup
plus que ça finalement on sait que
potentiellement on a 25 millions de
personnes mobilisables en Russie et
c'est 25 millions de personnes sont
aujourd'hui toutes très concernés par
cette mobilisation visiblement bref on
en saura plus dans les prochains jours
en attendant ces personnes ne sont pas
forcément des personnes formées
disons habitué aux conflit à haute
intensité elles n'ont pas forcément
l'habitude du terrain et on imagine du
coup qu'elle ressembleront davantage
avec tous les guillemets qui s'imposent
évidemment à de la chair à canon à autre
chose et on sait que sur le terrain
l'armée russe a avant tout besoin
d'armement puisqu'il y a un problème
d'acheminement ces derniers mois entre
justement les bas arrière que ce soit en
Biélorussie ou en Russie vers le front
et on sait que la Russie a fait par
exemple des demandes d'armement auprès
de la Corée du Nord et de l'Iran
récemment ça montre bien que la
problématique se situe également sur ce
terrain cette annonce on l'a vu dans le
sujet juste avant la provoqué
d'importantes manifestations en Russie à
travers tout le pays plus de 1300
personnes ont été arrêtées hier c'est la
plus forte mobilisation depuis le début
de cette guerre en Ukraine depuis fin
février elle a eu lieu d'ailleurs dans
plusieurs villes en une quarantaine de
villes donc pas seulement Moscou et
Saint-Pétersbourg est-ce qu'elle
pourrait déstabiliser Vladimir Poutine
le régime en place
disons que jusqu'à présent Vladimir
Poutine il rechignait la mobilisation
qu'elle soit partielle ou en général
parce qu'il savait justement que ça
allait agir comme un électrochoc auprès
de la population russe jusqu'à présent
lui souhaiter finalement garder la
population russe la plus passive
possible finalement la laisser en dehors
de ce conflit c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'on parlait de de on ne parlait pas de
guerre en Russie évidemment de mes
opérations de militaires spéciales
puisqu'il s'agissait de minimiser ce qui
se passait sur le terrain aujourd'hui
face à cette défaite militaires il n'a
pas le choix et évidemment les
conséquences elles sont elles peuvent
être très important puisque désormais il
n'y a pas une famille russe qui n'est
pas concernée en fait par cette
mobilisation potentielle comme je le
disais juste avant juste avant il y a
aujourd'hui 25 millions d'hommes qui
peuvent potentiellement être mobilisés
et qui sont mobilisables 25 millions en
Russie c'est tout simplement une
personne sur 6 donc une personne sur 6
c'est forcément une personne et
forcément une famille concerne donc à
partir de demain non on peut tout à fait
imaginer que cette ces manifestations
fasse effet boule de neige après on sait
que le régime russe est devenu de plus
en plus autoritaire et notamment depuis
le 24 février et qu'on insiste à une
répression systématique de la part des
manifestations et les autres il y a déjà
eu de très nombreuses victimes dans ce
conflit hier Vladimir Poutine a reconnu
la mort de 6000 soldats russes en
réalité ce chiffre devrait être bien
plus important déjà toutes ces victimes
on imagine c'est un impact dans la
société russe
oui bien sûr c'est un impact sachant que
évidemment les autorités russes parlent
de 5000 à 6000 morts sur le sur le
terrain certaines statistiques certaines
autorités notamment les autorités
américaines parlent plutôt de 60 à 70
000 morts sur le terrain même si c'est
évidemment très difficile de connaître
les vérités actuellement tout ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que dès lors qu'un
soldat russe décède sur le terrain
ensuite souvent le processus est le
suivant on envoie une urne funéraire
avec les cendres du soldat décédé à la
famille concernée et généralement on
intime la famille de garder le silence
et de ne pas protester sous peine
justement de dire que le soldat en
question était un déserteur et donc ça
jetterait en fait finalement l'eau
propre sur toute la famille donc on est
dans cette logique là effectivement si
les morts venaient à s'accumuler encore
et encore et encore alors on pourrait
tout à fait imaginer une contestation en
Russie notamment
pas uniquement après des hommes mais
aussi auprès des femmes et je pense
notamment aux maires de soldats qu'on a
vu manifester euh hier soir à Moscou
avec Saint-Pétersbourg notamment et
après l'annonce de cette mobilisation
partielle pour l'instant de nombreux
Russes se sont rués aussi sur les
billets d'avion vers l'étranger
notamment vers la Géorgie ou encore
l'Arménie comment on peut interpréter ça
intéressant c'est de voir dans le même
dans la dans la chronologie c'est à dire
qu'à partir du moment où la rumeur s'est
répandue selon laquelle Vladimir Poutine
allait parler donc c'était avant-hier
soir on a vu un pic dans les recherches
Google en Russie implique qui concernait
la phrase comment fuir la Russie donc
phrase écrite en russe sur sur Google
donc déjà on avait cette cette espèce de
traînée de poudre qui est qui a commencé
à arriver et puis on a vu effectivement
hier matin toutes les compagnies
aériennes présentes en Russie être
surchargés on a même eu des communiqués
de la part de aeroflots la compagnie
nationale russe l'aviation qui a dit que
elle l'avait pour le moment pas encore
reçu de consigne pour justement pour
justement refuser les hommes russes de
18 à 65 ans et j'insiste sur le fait
qu'elle a dit pas encore reçu le
consigne donc probablement qu'il y en
aura donc le temps et en fait je pense
que les hommes russes anticipent le fait
que les frontières risquent d'être
fermées dans les prochains jours ou les
prochaines semaines et tout ce qu'on
voit ces dernières heures en Russie
ces hommes ces gens qui qui tentent de
prendre des billets d'avion c'est
manifestations ces symptomatiques
finalement d'un malaise dans la société
russe face à cette guerre qui ne dit pas
son nom depuis le début oui complètement
on a la sensation jusqu'à présent la
société russe était plutôt passive face
à cette guerre peut-être qu'elle se
voilait la phase qu'elle ne voulait pas
regarder les choses en face ou alors que
elle était soumise finalement elle a
propagande de l'utérus néanmoins on a pu
observer certaines données alors il faut
savoir déjà une première chose c'est que
il est très difficile de savoir ce que
pense l'opinion en disant globale en
Russie aujourd'hui depuis début mars on
a des lois en Russie qui pénalisent ceux
qui s'opposent en fait frontalement
verbalement à l'opération militaire
spéciale comme on l'appelle là-bas donc
dès lors que vous avez un sondage
d'opinion il est forcément pas viable
puisque vous imaginez bien que c'est
très difficile pour une personne en
Russie aujourd'hui de dire non je ne
suis pas d'accord avec cette politique
bien entendu donc ça c'est la première
chose ensuite on a d'autres éléments qui
nous montrent qui laissent penser
finalement que la population russe se
détache peu à peu du gouvernement russe
et on peut penser notamment aux chaînes
de télévision d'État qui ont vu leur
audience baisser de 30% depuis le début
de du contenu depuis février jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il y a une forme de
d'éloignement de la population russe de
son gouvernement et actuellement les
réactions effectivement l'achat de
billets en masse le fait que aussi à la
frontière Russo finlandaise on a eu des
que énormes justement pendant sur
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres à la
frontière ça montre bien que il y a une
volonté de fuir le pays alors après
est-ce que cette volonté concerne une
majorité des populations russes c'est
très difficile de le dire actuellement
on a vu certains reportages liés
aujourd'hui qui montrait justement des
Russes des hommes russes aux avis très
disparaître on avait des hommes qui
étaient très contentes de partir
combattre sous le drapeau on avait
d'autres personnes qui cherchaient
absolument à se mutiler justement pour
ne pas pouvoir y aller donc en fait les
avis sont très divergents et il est très
difficile pour un observateur un
chercheur ou un journaliste de justement
statuer sur cette question Vlad une
routine qui s'est dit près aussi à
utiliser tous les moyens dans son
arsenal face à l'Occident qu'il accuse
de vouloir détruire la Russie clairement
il menace d'avoir recours à l'arme
nucléaire c'était déjà le cas au début
de cette garant en Ukraine est-ce qu'il
faut le prendre au sérieux Vladimir
Poutine
nucléaire comme son l'indique est une
arme de dissuasion avant tout il l'avait
utilisé on se souvient au tout début de
l'invasion une semaine après environ à
l'époque beaucoup d'observateurs
disaient qu'effectivement à partir du
moment où on emploie cet arbre de
dissasion aussitôt ça signifie qu'on est
en difficulté sur le terrain et les
observateurs ne se trompaient pas
aujourd'hui il y a cette volonté
finalement de relancer entre guillemets
la machine de donner du courage aux
soldats russes et de donner la sensation
au peuple russe que tout est sous
contrôle et que de toute façon
l'harmonie claire permet à la Russie
d'exister sur la scène internationale et
finalement d'avoir un impact
psychologique très important je pense
que pour le moment
encore au stade du bluff évidemment et
le fait de réutiliser cet argument une
deuxième fois et symptomatique du fait
finalement que le régime russe et
l'armée russe plutôt est acculé sur le
terrain en réalité il s'agit de relancer
la machine pour pouvoir effectivement
mettre en place ces référendum et
potentiellement avancer encore un peu
plus sur le terrain merci beaucoup Lucas
Aubin merci d'avoir été notre invité sur
France 24